one hit in you wouldn't test positive
how come there's a limit
one hit those little things for there's
a little bit of a limit some weights I
was running in Boulder Creek oh you mean
like a poppy seed right with the nose oh
my god what a weird feeling like I did
it but I got the blood the line was just
with my nose and the swab in there and
they're gonna [ __ ] it up cuz you know
you didn't test positive or code but you
get you need treatment kilos in your
[ __ ] mouth well the new one they
barely go inside you know they just they
used to have to go deep up into your
nose but now they just go into the
opening it's not that bad the new ones
not that bad it's like did you ever
thought about this we've never discussed
this this young generation not big and I
did the [ __ ] research when I was
growing up in the 70s you got a
thermometer in your [ __ ] yes they
should put it to marbling you [ __ ]
think of the result of what that did to
people if we go backwards we're gonna
see how many people are gay because for
years
sixteen what difference does it make
even putting up the model of my ass you
know meantime I don't think that's how
it works the thermometer it was the
creepiest thing people okay you went to
a doctor he sent over you'd be burning
up you'd have one of those Kovac fevers
he'd tell you to bend over he dipped it
to mom to Vaseline and he's stick it in
your ass like a minute and you had to
sit there with a [ __ ] thermometer in
your ass and look at him like make eye
contact and talk to him then he would
take it out wipe it and then not like
look real close tell you you 91.1 you
don't remember it the mom in the ass
Generosa remember them you think about
that [ __ ] I remember them in the mouth
too worried about that because you have
this metal [ __ ] rod in your mother
your bit too really that was done for a
while